It's certainly the latest in the
sense that this is going to be
more difficult for him to
actually get people like pence
and other top trump aides before
him to testify, Jim.
>> It will certainly drag this
process out.
That is always a trump playbook.
Jeremy herb, thank you very
much.
Appreciate that.
>>> Let's continue this
conversation.
Joining me now is former
congressman and candidate Joe
Walsh.
Great to see you.
Let's start with CPAC.
It's a magapaloosa.
What does this year's CPAC tell
you about the state of the GOP?
>> You know, Jim, I know the
temptation is to always laugh,
right?
Mike Lindell, Kari lake, Steve
Bannon, laugh at how crazy these
people are at CPAC, but we
shouldn't laugh.
I mean, this is -- this is
scary, and it's odd having to
say this six to seven years
after Donald Trump came on the
scene, but America needs to wake
up.
What we're seeing at CPAC right
now is the base.
The base of one of America's two
major political parties and it's
fully radicalized.
Virtually every speaker lied and
lied and lied.
It's been two or three days of
lies, disinformation, cruelty.
My god, Brazil's bolsonaro
spoke today about how his
election was stolen.
This is scary stuff.
The important point is, this is
where this Republican party is
because these are the activists.
>> And bolsonaro got the hero's
welcome despite the fact that
his own supporters stormed
buildings in Brazil to protest
his loss.
Nikki Haley was heckled a bit
when she was going after much
trump.
Mike Pompeo, he had a veiled jab
at trump.
Let's listen to this.
>> You can't become the left
following leaders with their own
brand identity of politics,
those with fragile egos who fail
to acknowledge reality.
>> It sounds like he's talking
about somebody we know.
>> Say his name, Mike!
Say his name!
My god, that's infewer yating.
You can't run for president and